who our staff was was saying they got
shot well I was thinking about this
whole thing that happened this shooting
in New Zealand yeah and then that
someone said you know you know who got
shot who got shot yeah go get him where
did he get shot he got robbed
Mike Mike Pearlman how you do Mike
what's up out hey so I was telling the
guys about New Zealand we were talking
about it you know a lot of people died
and stuff and then if someone blurted it
out that you'd been shot I didn't know
that yeah years ago what were you doing
I was coming out of a diner at like 5:00
in the morning this is like 4:30 the
morning where was this
Italy's like not okay that's my home
turf yeah so I was coming out of the
diner and there was two guys waiting for
me it says like as I said 5:00 in the
morning it was coming out and it was two
guys waiting for me one guy had a mask
on he has gone out and I was getting in
my car and you know and he was trying to
rob me just like give me all your [ __ ] I
was like [ __ ] you when I got my car oh
you said [ __ ] you the guys pointing a
gun at you and you said [ __ ] you oh
you're a real man I didn't know you were
such a man I was I could you know what I
couldn't live with myself a fight like
if you didn't say [ __ ] you you know I'm
a big coward I learned to live with
myself I'm like oh yes sir right here's
all my money sir and by the way nice
mask I don't think they expect me you
just got your car yeah I know then I got
in my car and as I was getting you know
it's just kind of moving to my car and
as I was getting in I was sitting in my
car about to close the door he was
standing there and he shot me right on
the side so in my chest
oh my chest and it went through my lung
through my stomach it to my liver Wow
and you survived and then I actually
drove after that I pulled the car out if
I put it we having trouble breathing
yeah what happ what happened was he ran
away and the guy that was with him kind
of stood there I guess they didn't
expect it cuz he was looking like what
you know what the [ __ ] he was in shock
and yeah and then they ran off and then
I pulled out the clouds go after him
right I pulled the car and I drove about
ten feet and then I stood like Robinson
I started breathing really weird Wow
someone wrote me you know Ronnie's in
the hall making fun of Mike's
storytelling ability what did Ronnie
what did what it might do wrong
he's gonna bust your balls now saying
you don't tell a good story Ronnie's
saying it can you imagine when you get
goose down when Ronnie where is he
get in here dude you said idiots out
there I just said the way he's telling
the story it's a funny way he's telling
the story that's all what does that mean
what's funny of us come back here what
do you mean what do you mean it's funny
now you
what does [ __ ] are you a critical in
his storytelling abilities yeah a little
bit I just said did see some storyteller
that's all you mean he didn't tell it
the right way no he told it the right
way but it's just the way some someone
who [ __ ] came out that's all so he's
funny yeah funny how like funny huh
funny yeah a little bit yeah
like a like he's telling the ladies John
Gotti yeah you know he's got all black
on he used to wear it's her double black
eye so he's calling me John Gotti now
this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you go
but the way you said it's not like wow
he's some storyteller this is some fire
god echo-y some storyteller okay that's
what I just said you didn't like the way
he told the story no I like the way he
told the story what is this John Gotti
crap you're giving it you got a scale of
1 to 10 how good a job did Mike do on
the air he got a tag he got a 10 what
kind of scale or we use it if you have a
problem with it I didn't have a profit I
just thought it was a little fun yeah
that story with [ __ ] he didn't say [ __ ]
once you want a story that's not what I
said so once upon a time for you are you
and Ronnie you're very good with this
story you got any other stories thank
you always more painful for you this
actual bullet or Ronnie's critique of
yeah with your [ __ ] shooting story I
got shot once I got shot once by a guy
who's shooting his load it was a nine
millimeter splat hold that together
buddy you start the lab wait you got a
scar where the bullet went in yeah let
me see that see that's where it went in
right there oh yeah yeah look at that
then it went in it and that's from my
coldest surgeries Wow and then they take
it out they took it out right there
somewhere
wow that's nothing I got a bruise on my
ass from Stephanie in the dildo show us
well Mike you're a real man I mean the
fact that I was no I'm just saying
because you made these comments that I
was making funny I'm summing up and I'm
saying no you don't have to leave I just
thought if you take it as a chaplain I
tell Mike he's a real man all of a
sudden you take that as a child I'm not
taking his angry yeah like what's
happened to you Mike no sorry
don't say Mike's a real man he took the
bullies doesn't mean you're not I didn't
say I was he's a real man and sometimes
I'm a real chick
yeah get away with that dildo